The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, good morning.
So today, we're going to have
a fairly packed lecture.
We are going to conclude
with chapter two,
discrete random variables.
And we will be talking
mostly about
multiple random variables.
And this is also the
last lecture as far
as quiz one is concerned.
So it's going to cover the
material until today, and of
course the next recitation
and tutorial as well.
OK, so we're going to review
quickly what we introduced at
the end of last lecture, where
we talked about the joint PMF
of two random variables.
We're going to talk about the
case of more than two random
variables as well.
We're going to talk about
the familiar concepts of
conditioning and independence,
but applied to random
variables instead of events.
We're going to look at the
expectations once more, talk
about a few properties that they
have, and then solve a
couple of problems and calculate
a few things in
somewhat clever ways.
So the first point I want to
make is that, to a large
extent, whatever is happening
in our chapter on discrete
random variables is just an
exercise in notation.
There is stuff and concepts that
you are already familiar
with-- probabilities,
probabilities of two things
happening, conditional
probabilities.
And all that we're doing, to
some extent, is rewriting
those familiar concepts
in new notation.
So for example, this
is the joint PMF
of two random variable.
It gives us, for any pair or
possible values of those
random variables, the
probability that that pair
occurs simultaneously.
So it's the probability that
simultaneously x takes that
value, and y takes
that other value.
And similarly, we have the
notion of the conditional PMF,
which is just a list of the --
condition of -- the various
conditional probabilities
of interest, conditional
probability that one random
variable takes this value
given that the other random
variable takes that value.
Now, a remark about conditional
probabilities.
Conditional probabilities
generally are like ordinary
probabilities.
You condition on something
particular.
So here we condition
on a particular y.
So think of little y as
a fixed quantity.
And then look at this
as a function of x.
So given that y, which we
condition on, given our new
universe, we're considering the
various possibilities for
x and the probabilities
that they have.
Now, the probabilities over
all x's, of course,
needs to add to 1.
So we should have a relation
of this kind.
So they're just like ordinary
probabilities over the
different x's in a universe
where we are told the value of
the random variable y.
Now, how are these related?
So we call these the marginal,
these the joint, these the
conditional.
And there are some relations
between these.
For example, to find the
marginal from the joint, it's
pretty straightforward.
The probability that x takes a
particular value is the sum of
the probabilities of all of the
different ways that this
particular value may occur.
What are the different ways?
Well, it may occur together with
a certain y, or together
with some other y, or together
with some other y.
So you look at all the possible
y's that can go
together with this x, and add
the probabilities of all of
those pairs for which we get
this particular value of x.
And then there's a relation
between that connects these
two probabilities with the
conditional probability.
And it's this relation.
It's nothing new.
It's just new notation for
writing what we already know,
that the probability of two
things happening is the
probability that the first thing
happens, and then given
that the first thing happens,
the probability that the
second one happened.
So how do we go from
one to the other?
Think of A as being the event
that X takes the value, little
x, and B being the event that
Y takes the value, little y.
So the joint probability is the
probability that these two
things happen simultaneously.
It's the probability that X
takes this value times the
conditional probability that Y
takes this value, given that X
took that first value.
So it's the familiar
multiplication rule, but just
transcribed in our
new notation.
So nothing new so far.
OK, why did we go through this
exercise and this notation?
It's because in the experiments
where we're
interested in the real world,
typically there's going to be
lots of uncertain quantities.
There's going to be multiple
random variables.
And we want to be able to talk
about them simultaneously.
Okay.
Why two and not more than two?
How about three random
variables?
Well, if you understand what's
going on in this slide, you
should be able to kind of
automatically generalize this
to the case of multiple
random variables.
So for example, if we have three
random variables, X, Y,
and Z, and you see an expression
like this, it
should be clear what it means.
It's the probability that
X takes this value and
simultaneously Y takes that
value and simultaneously Z
takes that value.
I guess that's an uppercase Z
here, that's a lowercase z.
And if I ask you to find the
marginal of X, if I tell you
the joint PMF of the three
random variables and I ask you
for this value, how
would you find it?
Well, you will try to generalize
this relation here.
The probability that x occurs
is the sum of the
probabilities of all events
that make X to take that
particular value.
So what are all the events?
Well, this particular x can
happen together with some y
and some z.
We don't care which y and z.
Any y and z will do.
So when we consider all
possibilities, we need to add
here over all possible values
of y's and z's.
So consider all triples,
x, y, z.
Fix x and consider all the
possibilities for the
remaining variables, y and z,
add these up, and that gives
you the marginal PMF of X. And
then there's other things that
you can do.
This is the multiplication
rule for two events.
We saw back in chapter one that
there's a multiplication
rule when you talk about
more than two events.
And you can write a chain of
conditional probabilities.
We can certainly do the same
in our new notation.
So let's look at this
rule up here.
Multiplication rule for three
random variables,
what does it say?
The probability of three
things happening
simultaneously, X, Y, Z taking
specific values, little x,
little y, little z, that
probability is the probability
that the first thing happens,
that X takes that value.
Given that X takes that value,
we multiply it with the
probability that Y takes
also a certain value.
And now, given that X and Y have
taken those particular
values, we multiply with a
conditional probability that
the third thing happens,
given that the
first two things happen.
So this is just the
multiplication rule for three
events, which would be
probability of A intersection
B intersection C equals--
you know the rest
of the formula.
You just rewrite this formula
in PMF notation.
Probability of A intersection
B intersection C is the
probability of A, which
corresponds to this term,
times the probability of B given
A, times the probability
of C given A and B.
So what else is there that's
left from chapter one that we
can or should generalize
to random variables?
Well, there's the notion
of independence.
So let's define what
independence means.
Instead of talking about just
two random variables, let's go
directly to the case of multiple
random variables.
When we talked about events,
things were a little
complicated.
We had a simple definition for
independence of two events.
Two events are independent if
the probability of both is
equal to the product of
the probabilities.
But for three events, it
was kind of messy.
We needed to write down
lots of conditions.
For random variables,
things in some sense
are a little simpler.
We only need to write down one
formula and take this as the
definition of independence.
Three random variables are
independent if and only if, by
definition, their joint
probability mass function
factors out into individual
probability mass functions.
So the probability that all
three things happen is the
product of the individual
probabilities that each one of
these three things
is happening.
So independence means
mathematically that you can
just multiply probabilities to
get to the probability of
several things happening
simultaneously.
So with three events, we have
to write a huge number of
equations, of equalities
that have to hold.
How can it be that with random
variables we can only manage
with one equality?
Well, the catch is
that this is not
really just one equality.
We require this to be true for
every little x, y, and z.
So in some sense, this is a
bunch of conditions that are
being put on the joint PMF, a
bunch of conditions that we
need to check.
So this is the mathematical
definition.
What is the intuitive content
of this definition?
The intuitive content is
the same as for events.
Random variables are independent
if knowing
something about the realized
values of some of these random
variables does not change our
beliefs about the likelihood
of various values for the
remaining random variables.
So independence would translate,
for example, to a
condition such as the
conditional PMF of X , given
y, should be equal to the
marginal PMF of X. What is
this saying?
That you have some original
beliefs about how likely it is
for X to take this value.
Now, someone comes and
tells you that Y took
on a certain value.
This causes you, in principle,
to revise your beliefs.
And your new beliefs will be
captured by the conditional
PMF, or the conditional
probabilities.
Independence means that your
revised beliefs actually will
be the same as your
original beliefs.
Telling you information about
the value of Y doesn't change
what you expect for the
random variable X.
Why didn't we use this
definition for independence?
Well, because this definition
only makes sense when this
conditional is well-defined.
And this conditional is only
well-defined if the events
that Y takes on that particular
value has positive
probability.
We cannot condition on events
that have zero probability, so
conditional probabilities are
only defined for y's that are
likely to occur, that have
a positive probability.
Now, similarly, with multiple
random variables, if they're
independent, you would have
relations such as the
conditional of X, given y and
z, should be the same as the
marginal of X. What
is this saying?
Again, that if I tell you the
values, the realized values of
random variables Y and Z, this
is not going to change your
beliefs about how likely
x is to occur.
Whatever you believed in the
beginning, you're going to
believe the same thing
afterwards.
So it's important to keep that
intuition in mind, because
sometimes this way you can tell
whether random variables
are independent without having
to do calculations and to
check this formula.
OK, so let's check our concepts
with a simple example.
Let's look at two random
variables that are discrete,
take values between
one and for each.
And this is a table that
gives us the joint PMF.
So it tells us the probability
that X equals to 2 and Y
equals to 1 happening
simultaneously.
It's an event that has
probability 1/20.
Are these two random variables
independent?
You can try to check a
condition like this.
But can we tell directly
from the table?
If I tell you a value of Y,
could that give you useful
information about X?
Certainly.
If I tell you that Y is equal
to 1, this tells you that X
must be equal to 2.
But if I tell you that Y was
equal to 3, this tells you
that, still, X could
be anything.
So telling you the value of
Y kind of changes what you
expect or what you consider
possible for the values of the
other random variable.
So by just inspecting here, we
can tell that the random
variables are not independent.
Okay.
What's the other concept we
introduced in chapter one?
We introduced the concept of
conditional independence.
And conditional independence is
like ordinary independence
but applied to a conditional
universe where we're given
some information.
So suppose someone tells you
that the outcome of the
experiment is such that X is
less than or equal to 2 and Y
is larger than or equal to 3.
So we are given the information
that we now live
inside this universe.
So what happens inside
this universe?
Inside this universe, our random
variables are going to
have a new joint PMF which is
conditioned on the event that
we were told that
it has occurred.
So let A correspond to this
sort of event here.
And now we're dealing with
conditional probabilities.
What are those conditional
probabilities?
We can put them in a table.
So it's a two by two table,
since we only have two
possible values.
What are they going to be?
Well, these probabilities
show up in the ratios
1, 2, 2, and 4.
Those ratios have to
stay the same.
The probabilities need
to add up to one.
So what should the denominators
be since these
numbers add up to nine?
These are the conditional
probabilities.
So this is the conditional
PMF in this example.
Now, in this conditional
universe, is x
independent from y?
If I tell you that y takes this
value, so we live in this
universe, what do you
know about x?
What you know about x is at this
value is twice as likely
as that value.
If I condition on y taking this
value, so we're living
here, what do you
know about x?
What you know about x is that
this value is twice as likely
as that value.
So it's the same.
Whether we live here or we live
there, this x is twice as
likely as that x.
So the conditional PMF in this
new universe, the conditional
PMF of X given y, in the new
universe is the same as the
marginal PMF of X, but of course
in the new universe.
So no matter what y is,
the conditional
PMF of X is the same.
And that conditional
PMF is 1/3 and 2/3.
This is the conditional PMF of
X in the new universe no
matter what y occurs.
So Y does not give us any
information about X, doesn't
cause us to change our beliefs
inside this little universe.
And therefore the two random
variables are independent.
Now, the other way that you
can verify that we have
independence is to find the
marginal PMFs of the two
random variables.
The marginal PMF of
X, you find it by
adding those two terms.
You get 1/3.
Adding those two terms,
you get 2/3.
Marginal PMF of Y, you find it,
you add these two terms,
and you get 1/3.
And the marginal PMF of Y
here is going to be 2/3.
And then you ask the question,
is the joint the product of
the marginals?
And indeed it is.
This times this gives you 1/9.
This times this gives you 2/9.
So the values in the table with
the joint PMFs is the
product of the marginal PMFs of
X and Y in this universe,
so the two random variables are
independent inside this universe.
So we say that they're
conditionally independent.
All right.
Now let's move to the new topic,
to the new concept that
we introduce in this chapter,
which is the concept of
expectations.
So what are the things
to know here?
One is the general idea.
The way to think about
expectations is that it's
something like the average value
for random variable if
you do an experiment over and
over, and if you interpret
probabilities as frequencies.
So you get x's over and over
with a certain frequency --
P(x) --
a particular value, little
x, gets realized.
And each time that this happens,
you get x dollars.
How many dollars do you
get on the average?
Well, this formula gives you
that particular average.
So first thing we do is to write
down a definition for
this sort of concept.
But then the other things you
need to know is how to
calculate expectations using
shortcuts sometimes, and what
properties they have.
The most important shortcut
there is is that, if you want
to calculate the expected value,
the average value for a
random variable, you do not need
to find the PMF of that
random variable.
But you can work directly with
the x's and the y's.
So you do the experiment
over and over.
The outcome of the experiment
is a pair (x,y).
And each time that a certain
(x,y) happens,
you get so many dollars.
So this fraction of the time,
a certain (x,y) happens.
And that fraction of the time,
you get so many dollars, so
this is the average number
of dollars that you get.
So what you end up, since it
is the average, then that
means that it corresponds
to the expected value.
Now, this is something that, of
course, needs a little bit
of mathematical proof.
But this is just a different
way of accounting.
And it turns out we give
you the right answer.
And it's a very useful
shortcut.
Now, when we're talking about
functions of random variables,
in general, we cannot speak
just about averages.
That is, the expected value
of a function of a random
variable is not the same
as the function of
the expected values.
A function of averages is
not the same as the
average of a function.
So in general, this
is not true.
But what it's important to know
is to know the exceptions
to this rule.
And the important exceptions
are mainly two.
One is the case of linear
functions of a random variable.
We discussed this last time.
So the expected value of
temperature in Celsius is, you
first find the expected value of
temperature in Fahrenheit,
and then you do the conversion
to Celsius.
So whether you first average and
then do the conversion to
the new units or not, it
shouldn't matter when you get
the result.
The other property that turns
out to be true when you talk
about multiple random variables
is that expectation
still behaves linearly.
So let X, Y, and Z be the score
of a random student at
each one of the three
sections of the SAT.
So the overall SAT score is X
plus Y plus Z. This is the
average score, the average
total SAT score.
Another way to calculate that
average is to look at the
first section of the SAT and
see what was the average.
Look at the second section, look
at what was the average,
and so the third, and
add the averages.
So you can do the averages for
each section separately, add
the averages, or you can find
total scores for each student
and average them.
So I guess you probably believe
that this is correct
if you talk just about
averaging scores.
Since expectations are just the
variation of averages, it
turns out that this is
also true in general.
And the derivation of this is
very simple, based on the
expected value rule.
And you can look at
it in the notes.
So this is one exception,
which is linearity.
The second important exception
is the case of independent
random variables, that the
product of two random
variables has an expectation
which is the product of the
expectations.
In general, this is not true.
But for the case where we have
independence, the expectation
works out as follows.
Using the expected value rule,
this is how you calculate the
expected value of a function
of a random variable.
So think of this as being your
g(X, Y) and this being your
g(little x, y).
So this is something that's
generally true.
Now, if we have independence,
then the PMFs factor out, and
then you can separate this sum
by bringing together the x
terms, bring them outside
the y summation.
And you find that this is the
same as expected value of X
times the expected value of Y.
So independence is used in
this step here.
OK, now what if X and Y are
independent, but instead of
taking the expectation of
X times Y, we take the
expectation of the product of
two functions of X and Y?
I claim that the expected value
of the product is still
going to be the product of
the expected values.
How do we show that?
We could show it by just redoing
this derivation here.
Instead of X and Y, we would
have g(X) and h(Y), so the
algebra goes through.
But there's a better way to
think about it which is more
conceptual.
And here's the idea.
If X and Y are independent,
what does it mean?
X does not convey any
information about Y. If X
conveys no information about Y,
does X convey information
about h(Y)?
No.
If X tells me nothing about Y,
nothing new, it shouldn't tell
me anything about h(Y).
Now, if X tells me nothing about
h of h(Y), could g(X)
tell me something about h(Y)?
No.
So the idea is that, if X is
unrelated to Y, doesn't have
any useful information, then
g(X) could not have any useful
information for h(Y).
So if X and Y are independent,
then g(X) and h(Y) are also
independent.
So this is something that
one can try to prove
mathematically, but it's more
important to understand
conceptually why this is so.
It's in terms of conveying
information.
So if X tells me nothing about
Y, X cannot tell me anything
about Y cubed, or X cannot
tell me anything by Y
squared, and so on.
That's the idea.
And once we are convinced that
g(X) and h(Y) are independent,
then we can apply our previous
rule, that for independent
random variables, expectations
multiply the right way.
Apply the previous rule, but
apply it now to these two
independent random variables.
And we get the conclusion
that we wanted.
Now, besides expectations, we
also introduced the concept of
the variance.
And if you remember the
definition of the variance,
let me write down the formula
for the variance of aX.
It's the expected value of the
random variable that we're
looking at minus the expected
value of the random variable
that we're looking at.
So this is the difference
of the random
variable from its mean.
And we take that difference
and square it, so it's the
squared distance from the
mean, and then take
expectations of the
whole thing.
So when you look at that
expression, you realize that a
can be pulled out of
those expressions.
And because there is a squared,
when you pull out the
a, it's going to come
out as an a-squared.
So that gives us the rule for
finding the variance of a
scale or product of
a random variable.
The variance captures the idea
of how wide, how spread out a
certain distribution is.
Bigger variance means it's
more spread out.
Now, if you take a random
variable and the constants to
it, what does it do to
its distribution?
It just shifts it, but it
doesn't change its width.
So intuitively it
means that the
variance should not change.
You can check that
mathematically, but it should
also make sense intuitively.
So the variance, when you add
the constant, does not change.
Now, can you add variances is
the way we added expectations?
Does variance behave linearly?
It turns out that not always.
Here, we need a condition.
It's only in special cases--
for example, when the two
random variables are
independent--
that you can add variances.
The variance of the sum is the
sum of the variances if X and
Y are independent.
The derivation of this is,
again, very short and simple.
We'll skip it, but it's an
important fact to remember.
Now, to appreciate why this
equality is not true always,
we can think of some
extreme examples.
Suppose that X is the same as
Y. What's going to be the
variance of X plus Y?
Well, X plus Y, in this case,
is the same as 2X, so we're
going to get 4 times the
variance of X, which is
different than the variance of
X plus the variance of X.
So that expression would give
us twice the variance of X.
But actually now it's 4 times
the variance of X. The other
extreme would be if X is equal
to -Y. Then the variance is
the variance of the random
variable, which is always
equal to 0.
Now, a random variable which
is always equal to 0 has no
uncertainty.
It is always equal to its mean
value, so the variance, in
this case, turns out to be 0.
So in both of these cases,
of course we have random
variables that are extremely
dependent.
Why are they dependent?
Because if I tell you something
about Y, it tells
you an awful lot about the value
of X. There's a lot of
information about X if
I tell you Y, in this
case or in that case.
And finally, a short drill.
If I tell you that the random
variables are independent and
you want to calculate the
variance of a linear
combination of this kind,
then how do you argue?
You argue that, since X and Y
are independent, this means
that X and 3Y are also
independent.
X has no information about Y, so
X has no information about
-Y. X has no information about
-Y, so X should not have any
information about -3Y.
So X and -3Y are independent.
So the variance of Z should be
the variance of X plus the
variance of -3Y, which is the
variance of X plus 9 times the
variance of Y. The important
thing to note here is that no
matter what happens, you
end up getting a
plus here, not a minus.
So that's the sort of important
thing to remember in
this type of calculation.
So this has been all concepts,
reviews, new
concepts and all that.
It's the usual fire hose.
Now let's use them to do
something useful finally.
So let's revisit our old
example, the binomial
distribution, which counts the
number of successes in
independent trials of a coin.
It's a biased coin that has
a probability of heads, or
probability of success, equal
to p at each trial.
Finally, we can go through the
exercise of calculating the
expected value of this
random variable.
And there's the way of
calculating that expectation
that would be the favorite
of those people who enjoy
algebra, which is to write down
the definition of the
expected value.
We add over all possible values
of the random variable,
over all the possible k's, and
weigh them according to the
probabilities that this
particular k occurs.
The probability that X takes on
a particular value k is, of
course, the binomial
PMF, which is
this familiar formula.
Clearly, that would be a messy
and challenging calculation.
Can we find a shortcut?
There's a very clever trick.
There's lots of problems in
probability that you can
approach really nicely by
breaking up the random
variable of interest into a
sum of simpler and more
manageable random variables.
And if you can make it to be a
sum of random variables that
are just 0's or 1's,
so much the better.
Life is easier.
Random variables that take
values 0 or 1, we call them
indicator variables.
They indicate whether an event
has occurred or not.
In this case, we look at each
coin flip one at a time.
For the i-th flip, if it
resulted in heads or a
success, we record it 1.
If not, we record it 0.
And then we look at the
random variable.
If we take the sum of the Xi's,
what is it going to be?
We add one each time that we get
a success, so the sum is
going to be the total
number of successes.
So we break up the random
variable of interest as a sum
of really nice and simple
random variables.
And now we can use the linearity
of expectations.
We're going to find the
expectation of X by finding
the expectation of the Xi's
and then adding the
expectations.
What's the expected
value of Xi?
Well, Xi takes the value 1 with
probability p, and takes
the value 0 with probability
1-p.
So the expected value
of Xi is just p.
So the expected value of X is
going to be just n times p.
Because X is the sum of n terms,
each one of which has
expectation p, the expected
value of the sum is the sum of
the expected values.
So I guess that's a pretty good
shortcut for doing this
horrendous calculation
up there.
So in case you didn't realize
it, that's what we just
established without
doing any algebra.
Good.
How about the variance
of X, of Xi?
Two ways to calculate it.
One is by using directly the
formula for the variance,
which would be --
let's see what it would be.
With probability
p, you get a 1.
And in this case, you are
so far from the mean.
That's your squared distance
from the mean.
With probability 1-p, you
get a 0, which is so far
away from the mean.
And then you can simplify that
formula and get an answer.
How about a slightly easier
way of doing it.
Instead of doing the algebra
here, let me indicate the
slightly easier way.
We have a formula for the
variance that tells us that we
can find the variance by
proceeding this way.
That's a formula that's
generally true for variances.
Why is this easier?
What's the expected value
of Xi squared?
Backtrack.
What is Xi squared, after all?
It's the same thing as Xi.
Since Xi takes value 0 and 1, Xi
squared also takes the same
values, 0 and 1.
So the expected value of Xi
squared is the same as the
expected value of Xi,
which is equal to p.
And the expected value of Xi
squared is p squared, so we
get the final answer,
p times (1-p).
If you were to work through and
do the cancellations in
this messy expression here,
after one line you would also
get to the same formula.
But this sort of illustrates
that working with this formula
for the variance, sometimes
things work
out a little faster.
Finally, are we in business?
Can we calculate the variance
of the random
variable X as well?
Well, we have the rule that
for independent random
variables, the variance
of the sum is
the sum of the variances.
So to find the variance of X,
we just need to add the
variances of the Xi's.
We have n Xi's, and each
one of them has
variance p_n times (1-p).
And we are done.
So this way, we have calculated
both the mean and
the variance of the binomial
random variable.
It's interesting to look at this
particular formula and
see what it tells us.
If you are to plot the variance
of X as a function of
p, it has this shape.
And the maximum is
here at 1/2.
p times (1-p) is 0 when
p is equal to 0.
And when p equals to 1, it's a
quadratic, so it must have
this particular shape.
So what does it tell us?
If you think about variance as
a measure of uncertainty, it
tells you that coin flips
are most uncertain when
your coin is fair.
When p is equal to 1/2, that's
when you have the most
randomness.
And this is kind of intuitive.
if on the other hand I tell you
that the coin is extremely
biased, p very close to 1, which
means it almost always
gives you heads, then
that would be
a case of low variance.
There's low variability
in the results.
There's little uncertainty about
what's going to happen.
It's going to be mostly heads
with some occasional tails.
So p equals 1/2.
Fair coin, that's the coin which
is the most uncertain of
all coins, in some sense.
And it corresponds to the
biggest variance.
It corresponds to an X that has
the widest distribution.
Now that we're on a roll and we
can calculate such hugely
complicated sums in simple ways,
let us try to push our
luck and do a problem with
this flavor, but a little
harder than that.
So you go to one of those
old-fashioned cocktail parties.
All males at least will have
those standard big hats which
look identical.
They check them in when
they walk in.
And when they walk out, since
they look pretty identical,
they just pick a random
hat and go home.
So n people, they pick their
hats completely at random,
quote, unquote, and
then leave.
And the question is, to say
something about the number of
people who end up, by accident
or by luck, to get back their
own hat, the exact same hat
that they checked in.
OK, first what do we mean
completely at random?
Completely at random, we
basically mean that any
permutation of the hats
is equally likely.
Any way of distributing those
n hats to the n people, any
particular way is as likely
as any other way.
So there's complete symmetry
between hats and people.
So what we want to do is to
calculate the expected value
and the variance of this random
variable X. Let's start
with the expected value.
Let's reuse the trick from
the binomial case.
So total number of hats picked,
we're going to think
of total number of hats
picked as a sum of
(0, 1) random variables.
X1 tells us whether person
1 got their own hat back.
If they did, we record a 1.
X2, the same thing.
By adding all X's is how many
1's did we get, which counts
how many people selected
their own hats.
So we broke down the random
variable of interest, the
number of people who get their
own hats back, as a sum of
random variables.
And these random variables,
again, are easy to handle,
because they're binary.
The only take two values.
What's the probability that Xi
is equal to 1, the i-th person
has a probability that they
get their own hat?
There's n hats by symmetry.
The chance is that they end up
getting their own hat, as
opposed to any one of the
other n - 1 hats,
is going to be 1/n.
So what's the expected
value of Xi?
It's one times 1/n.
With probability 1/n, you get
your own hat, or you get a
value of 0 with probability
1-1/n, which is 1/n.
All right, so we got the
expected value of the Xi's.
And remember, we want to do is
to calculate the expected
value of X by using this
decomposition?
Are the random variables Xi
independent of each other?
You can try to answer that
question by writing down a
joint PMF for the X's,
but I'm sure that
you will not succeed.
But can you think intuitively?
If I tell you information about
some of the Xi's, does
it give you information about
the remaining ones?
Yeah.
If I tell you that out of 10
people, 9 of them got their
own hat back, does that
tell you something
about the 10th person?
Yes.
If 9 got their own hat, then the
10th must also have gotten
their own hat back.
So the first 9 random variables
tell you something
about the 10th one.
And conveying information of
this sort, that's the case of
dependence.
All right, so the random
variables are not independent.
Are we stuck?
Can we still calculate the
expected value of X?
Yes, we can.
And the reason we can is that
expectations are linear.
Expectation of a sum of random
variables is the sum of the
expectations.
And that's always true.
There's no independence
assumption that's being used
to apply that rule.
So we have that the expected
value of X is the sum of the
expected value of the Xi's.
And this is a property
that's always true.
You don't need independence.
You don't care.
So we're adding n terms,
each one of which has
expected value 1/n.
And the final answer is 1.
So out of the 100 people who
selected hats at random, on
the average, you expect only one
of them to end up getting
their own hat back.
Very good.
So since we are succeeding so
far, let's try to see if we
can succeed in calculating
the variance as well.
And of course, we will.
But it's going to be a little
more complicated.
The reason it's going to be a
little more complicated is
because the Xi's are not
independent, so the variance
of the sum is not the same as
the sum of the variances.
So it's not enough to find the
variances of the Xi's.
We'll have to do more work.
And here's what's involved.
Let's start with the general
formula for the variance,
which, as I mentioned before,
it's usually the simpler way
to go about calculating
variances.
So we need to calculate the
expected value for X-squared,
and subtract from it the
expectation squared.
Well, we already found the
expected value of X. It's
equal to 1.
So 1-squared gives us just 1.
So we're left with the task of
calculating the expected value
of X-squared, the random
variable X-squared.
Let's try to follow
the same idea.
Write this messy random
variable, X-squared, as a sum
of hopefully simpler
random variables.
So X is the sum of the
Xi's, so you square
both sides of this.
And then you expand the
right-hand side.
When you expand the right-hand
side, you get the squares of
the terms that appear here.
And then you get all
the cross-terms.
For every pair of (i,j) that
are different, i different
than j, you're going to have
a cross-term in the sum.
So now, in order to calculate
the expected value of
X-squared, what does
our task reduce to?
It reduces to calculating the
expected value of this term
and calculating the expected
value of that term.
So let's do them
one at a time.
Expected value of Xi squared,
what is it going to be?
Same trick as before.
Xi takes value 0 or 1, so Xi
squared takes just the same
values, 0 or 1.
So that's the easy one.
That's the same as expected
value of Xi, which we already
know to be 1/n.
So this gives us a first
contribution down here.
The expected value of this
term is going to be what?
We have n terms in
the summation.
And each one of these terms
has an expectation of 1/n.
So we did a piece
of the puzzle.
So now let's deal with the
second piece of the puzzle.
Let's find the expected
value of Xi times Xj.
Now by symmetry, the expected
value of Xi times Xj is going
to be the same no matter
what i and j you see.
So let's just think about X1
and X2 and try to find the
expected value of X1 and X2.
X1 times X2 is a random
variable.
What values does it take?
Only 0 or 1?
Since X1 and X2 are 0 or 1,
their product can only take
the values of 0 or 1.
So to find the probability
distribution of this random
variable, it's just sufficient
to find the probability that
it takes the value of 1.
Now, what does X1 times
X2 equal to 1 mean?
It means that X1 was
1 and X2 was 1.
The only way that you can get
a product of 1 is if both of
them turned out to be 1's.
So that's the same as saying,
persons 1 and 2 both picked
their own hats.
The probability that person 1
and person 2 both pick their
own hats is the probability of
two things happening, which is
the product of the first thing
happening times the
conditional probability
of the second, given
that the first happened.
And in words, this is the
probability that the first
person picked their own hat
times the probability that the
second person picks their own
hat, given that the first
person already picked
their own.
So what's the probability
that the first person
picks their own hat?
We know that it's 1/n.
Now, how about the
second person?
If I tell you that one person
has their own hat, and that
person takes their hat and goes
away, from the point of
view of the second person,
there's n - 1 people left
looking at n - 1 hats.
And they're getting just
hats at random.
What's the chance that
I will get my own?
It's 1/n - 1.
So think of them as person 1
goes, picks a hat at random,
it happens to be their
own, and it leaves.
You're left with n - 1 people,
and there are n
- 1 hats out there.
Person 2 goes and picks a hat
at random, with probability
1/n - 1, is going to
pick his own hat.
So the expected value now of
this random variable is,
again, that same number,
because this is
a 0, 1 random variable.
So this is the same as expected
value of Xi times Xj
when i different than j.
So here, all that's left to do
is to add the expectations of
these terms.
Each one of these terms has an
expected value that's 1/n
times (1/n - 1).
And how many terms do we have?
How many of these are
we adding up?
It's n-squared - n.
When you expand the quadratic,
there's a total
of n-squared terms.
Some are self-terms,
n of them.
And the remaining number of
terms is n-squared - n.
So here we got n-squared
- n terms.
And so we need to multiply
here with n-squared - n.
And after you realize that this
number here is 1, and you
realize that this is the same
as the denominator, you get
the answer that the expected
value of X squared equals 2.
And then, finally going up to
the top formula, we get the
expected value of X squared,
which is 2 - 1, and the
variance is just equal to 1.
So the variance of this random
variable, number of people who
get their own hats back,
is also equal to 1,
equal to the mean.
Looks like magic.
Why is this the case?
Well, there's a deeper
explanation why these two
numbers should come out
to be the same.
But this is something that would
probably have to wait a
couple of chapters before we
could actually explain it.
And so I'll stop here.